pro-democracy protesters in hong kong
have defied a police ban and
taken to the streets once again riot
police fired tear gas and water canyons
with blue dye at demonstrators who
hurled rocks and petrol bombs the rally
through a
downtown hong kong shopping district
descended into violence when
groups of hardcore activists tried to
attack the city's main government
complex
there was also an attack on the subway
station demonstrators are calling for
international support in their
months-long pro-democracy campaign
now our reporter matthias bulinger is in
hong kong and
joins us now for more hi matthias good
to see you so
people are back on the streets and their
numbers what's happening now where you
are
well people have first gathered around
the government headquarters and
the parliament the legislature they have
been dispersed with tear gas
and water cannons from there
and then now they're moving around the
city just a moment ago
there were lots of protesters here now
they've moved to other streets and
they're
regrouping over there as you can see so
everybody is on the move the protesters
in the streets of hong kong
and the police behind them matias
the the protests were initially
triggered by an extradition bill that
has since
been withdrawn why are people still
taking to the streets why are they still
protesting
if this withdrawal had come in the very
beginning after the first mass
demonstrations
then probably everything would have
ended soon but since these protests have
begun
so much anger has built up anger mostly
at the police force that has
been using tear gas and rubber bullets
and
what protesters and many hong kongers
see as excessive violence
so the an investigation into police
violence is one of the
main demands of the protesters and this
slow reaction of the government paired
with this
uh harsh reaction of the police and and
and and this uh willingness to use
violence
against the protesters has also
convinced many people
that they should stand up to their
demand of universal suffrage
that to elect their government
themselves they are not happy with the
system they have not been happy
with this system that guarantees beijing
as say in appointing
uh the uh chief executive the head of
government
and the more this has been continuing
the more people feel
that this system is broken and they need
a political reform
one more to you matthias and perhaps
answer this one very quickly yesterday
we saw
um some clashes between pro-beijing
supporters and pro-democracy supporters
how polarized would you say hong kong is
right now
well the cleavage between the two camps
is getting bigger
you can imagine all these pictures of
violence violence by the police but also
by the protesters
are of course driving people closer
together in their own camp from service
we
we know that most hong kongers a
majority is standing behind the demands
of the protesters
uh unease with the political system has
been growing over the past five years
when beijing interfered more and more
directly into hong kong politics
so uh probably the majority is standing
with the protesters although they might
not
be uh approve of all of the methods they
use and the violence
right that's mathias bowling in hong
kong thank you